[Music]
[Applause]
on tuesday
jeff bezos and three other passengers
successfully completed
the first manned mission of blue
origin's new shepard spacecraft
go jeff go marco wally go oliver you are
going to space this was the 16th
successful flight for the new shepherd
but the first with astronauts on board
look at the blackness of space what
we're doing
is the first step was something big
and i know what that feels like i did it
three decades ago almost three decades
ago
with amazon and we are
big things start small the successful
flight is yet another remarkable
accomplishment
for one of the world's most successful
entrepreneurs
the amazon founder and former ceo
amassed one of the world's greatest
fortunes
by revolutionizing the retail and
computing businesses
and accelerating the transition to
e-commerce
jeff bezos started amazon in 1994
and served as chief executive for 27
years
he built the company from an online
bookseller into a modern colossus
that dominates american e-commerce and
is a major player
in businesses ranging from cloud
computing to digital advertising
to logistics to entertainment
born in albuquerque new mexico bezos
graduated
as valedictorian with a 4.76 gpa
from a suburban miami high school in
1982.
bezos attended princeton university
after graduation
he went into finance eventually joining
the hedge fund d.e shawn company
in 1993 bezos left his job and decided
to start an online bookstore
he named his new company amazon after
the amazon river in south america
which seemed fitting because it was the
earth's largest river
and he was planning to build the world's
largest bookstore
three years after bezos founded amazon
he took it public
the remarkable rise of amazon's share
price helped build bezos personal wealth
which allowed him to launch his space
tourism company blue origin
since 2000 bezos has funded the company
by selling one billion dollars worth of
amazon stock each year
you see the earth from space and it
changes you it changes your relationship
with this planet with humanity i want to
go on this flight
because it's a thing i've wanted to do
all my life
in the mid 2000s amazon expanded rapidly
with the introduction of new products
prime aws and the kindle
in 2013 bezos purchased the washington
post for 250 million dollars
[Music]
more recently amazon has made big ticket
acquisitions
buying up the streaming service twitch
grocer whole foods
and this year the hollywood studio mgm
[Music]
despite a long list of successes
amazon's rapid growth
hasn't been without its challenges
amazon says it will not be building a
second headquarters in new york city in
2018
amazon scrapped plans for new york city
facility
after local pushback last july the ceos
of amazon apple
facebook and google faced tough
questions about their business practices
during a house antitrust hearing mr
basils are
are stolen goods sold on amazon with
over a million
sellers i'm sure that it has happened um
but
certainly i don't think it's a large
part of what we're selling
okay so mr basil's basically then you're
saying yes
i guess so as it has grown in size and
power amazon has faced increased
criticism over everything
from the company's business tactics to
the treatment of its massive workforce
responsible for moving goods from its
warehouses to consumers doorsteps
after 27 years jeff bezos officially
handing the reins over to amazon web
services chief executive
andy jassy in july of this year
just a few weeks before his flight into
space bezos stepped down from a ceo role
at amazon to become an executive chair
focused on innovation
bezos said he plans to focus more of his
energy and his two other properties
the washington post and blue origin
we're going to build a road to space
so that our kids and their kids can
build the future
the amazon founder has poured billions
into his space venture over more than
two decades
believing humanity must ultimately
establish
outposts across the solar system